hey everyone
we have an exciting topic for today in
this video we'll compare the two most
popular job roles in the field of
information technology
that is business analyst versus data
analyst we'll understand the differences
between a business analyst and a data
analyst
in terms of their job description the
responsibilities for each of these roles
and the various skills they possess
you will get an idea about the salary
structure of a business analyst and that
of a data analyst
and we will also look at the companies
hiring for these roles
finally towards the end of this video
i'll tell you how simply learn can help
you with your career
as a business analyst and as a data
analyst
first let's understand the job
description of a business analyst
business analyst is a professional who
bridges the gap between the it and the
business teams in an organization they
use data analytics and modern
technologies to assess processes
and deliver data-driven solutions they
understand and solve a business problem
and validate business requirements
a business analyst generates reports for
executives and stakeholders
they are part of the business operation
and work closely with the technology
team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered
they also assist in the integration and
testing of new solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst
with the rapid increase in data
generation today the term data analyst
has found its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats
this data can be in the form of customer
information and feedback
log files transaction data marketing
research and so on
it is the duty of a data analyst to
transform these business data into
valuable insights
some of the problems that can be
addressed are how to improve a business
how to provide good customer experience
what would be the ideal price for a new
product
how to reduce transportation costs and
so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and reporting
with this brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst
let's now shift our focus towards the
various responsibilities of a business
analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost-effective solution to tackle
the issues
they thoroughly understand the
requirements from the clients and assign
the right resources
bas communicate and work closely with
the development team to design the
solution for a problem
they ensure that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
the stakeholders requirements and often
give
iterative feedback on the solution being
developed they check and validate if the
project is running fine with the help of
user acceptance testing
they also verify if the solution being
worked on is in line with the
requirements and ensure that the final
product
satisfies the user expectations bas
assess the functional and non-functional
requirements
a business analyst documents the project
findings and results
they present the project conclusions to
the stakeholders and clients
along with delivering maintenance
reports and building visualizations to
make decisions
now let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst
first and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan
and streamline the analysis process data
analysts collect data from various
heterogeneous sources
they assess the available resources
comprehend the business problem
and gather the right data for analysis
they work
closely with different team members like
programmers business analysts and data
scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst
the data collected is often noisy and it
contains missing values
hence it is crucial to clean the
collected data and remove invalid values
to make it ready for analysis
they use a variety of analytical
statistical and business intelligence
tools to spot trends
and patterns in complex data sets
discover hidden insights and prepare
summary reports for the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a ba
a business analyst should have a
graduation degree in any relevant field
such as business
accounting information systems human
resources or engineering
you can apply for entry level business
analyst positions or with professional
experience
excel is a powerful analytics and
reporting tool for working with data
bas use excel to perform various
calculations data
analysis plan an editorial calendar and
calculate customer discounts to derive
meaningful insights and take decisions
bas use sql to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases
critical thinking skills are important
to understand customers business needs
it allows them to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business
and those that should be given a lower
priority
base should find different ways to
address each challenge
data visualization is a key skill for
bas to build interactive dashboards and
reports to convey the outcomes of a
project
knowledge of tableau power bi and qlik
view is required to make different types
of reports depending on the business
requirements
business analysts should have a good
hands-on programming experience to solve
complex tasks and perform faster
analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as r and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicated in front of
the stakeholders and clients
let's now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess
you must have a bachelor's degree in any
relevant field or be
a graduate in statistics economics or
science
you're eligible to become a data analyst
being a fresher or as an experienced
professional
you should have domain knowledge in the
field you are working in
once again knowledge of excel is another
basic requirement for a data analyst
data analysts often work with structured
data so they should be proficient in
writing sql queries using data
manipulation
and data definition commands they should
know how to create stored procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on
experience with programming languages
such as python r
sas and javascript you can analyze and
visualize large
sets and create predictive models for
making business decisions
data analysts create data visualizations
using libraries such as matplotlib
c-bond ggplot and plotly this helps them
to perform
exploratory data analysis knowledge of
tableau and power bi is required to
create different business reports with
the help of graphs and charts
data analysts should have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms to build
sophisticated models and make future
predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression
support vector machines k-mean
clustering and other supervised and
unsupervised learning algorithms finally
data analysts should also possess good
communication and presentation skills
now let's discuss the salary structure
for both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the united states
earns an average salary of 69 000
while in india you can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum
now talking about the salary of a data
analyst according to pay scale in the
u.s a data analyst earns an average
salary of sixty thousand seven hundred
and ten dollars per annum
and in india you can earn around four
lakhs twenty four thousand rupees per
annum
let's now move on and look at the
different companies hiring for business
analyst roles
here we have oracle the search engine
giant google
the american mnc cognizant and
e-commerce company amazon
in addition to that we have ernest and
young technology giant ibm
dell and cisco hiring business analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have twitter
google the social media leader facebook
and amazon
we also have the american oil company
shell the electric vehicle company tesla
apple and the american credit reporting
agency equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have
check what skills you possess and the
domain knowledge you have
then gauge your interest to see what
suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career as a business
analyst and a data analyst
simplylearn offers a postgraduate
program in business analysis
that is in collaboration with purdue
university
the endorsed education provider is iiba
some of the skills that will be covered
in this course are strategy analysis
wireframing solution evaluation
dashboarding
data visualization agile scrum
methodology
scrum artifacts statistical analysis
using excel and sql database
some of the tools covered in this course
are microsoft excel
tableau power bi jira postgresql
planbox and others some of the key
features of this business analysis
program are you will receive purdue post
graduate program certification
master classes from purdue faculty you
can enroll in simply learn's job assist
where you will get im jobs pro
membership for 6 months
and obtain 35 iiba pd cdus
and 25 pmi pdus you will get 170 plus
hours of blended learning along with
capstone projects in three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the postgraduate program in data
analytics
offered by simply learn this program is
in collaboration with perturb university
and ibm
the skills that will be covered as a
part of the course are statistical
analysis using excel
data analysis in python and are data
visualization using tableau and power bi
linear and logistic regression modules
clustering using k-means
supervised learning and others the tools
that you will learn
are numpy pandas scipy scikit-learn
excel and others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get purge your
post-graduate program certification
industry recognized ibm certificates
enrollment and simply learns job assist
and master classes from purdue faculty
you have 180 plus hours of blended
learning 14 plus hands-on projects on
integrated labs and capstone projects in
three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
with that we have come to the end of
this video on business analyst versus
data analyst
i hope you have found this informative
and helpful
if you enjoyed this video please like
and share it and don't forget to
subscribe to the simply learn channel
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here